So it is today the 18th anniversary of nine
11. It's incredible. It has actually been,
uh, more than half of my life has been lived
after nine 11 than before nine 11, which is
incredible. It's also incredible just how
fast time passes and with each passing year
since nine 11, uh, since the program has existed,
uh, I have been increasingly unsure, I guess
I would say, or kind of just ambivalent about
what should we be doing? Should we just be
doing the same thing every nine 11 anniversary
more or less? I don't know. It's actually
been a few years since we've even talked about
it because for the last several anniversaries,
I just didn't really have anything new to
add. So what I want to think about today is
I will retell the story of, of where I was
on nine 11, which I remember vividly, although
behavioral economists and others would say,
my memory of this has deteriorated over the
years and it is no longer accurate, but you
can go back and check contrast with the first
time I told the story.
And then I also want to talk about the, the
sort of legacy of nine 11 as I now see it.
So, uh, on, on the morning of nine 11, I was
in high school and I was sitting in psychology
class with a teacher of mine who I really
liked Donald Palmisano, who sadly is no longer
with us. He actually passed away not that
long ago and I got the chance to see him out
in western Massachusetts at an event a few
years ago. And, um, I remember his wife actually
came up to me having heard my description
of, uh, my nine 11 morning and said, you know
what, when I heard you tell that story, I
asked him, is it, do you think it really went
down that way? And he said, you know, I don't
remember, but it sounds sort of like how it
would go down. So I was sitting in psychology
class and, um, a student who was sort of a
regular troublemaker, whose name I forgot,
I think his name might have been Eric.
And it's amazing that his, the, the student's
name, I forgotten. He was always out of his
seat and always walking around in the halls.
He had gone to the bathroom and he came back
into the room, uh, agitated and interrupted
psychology class and said to Mr Palmisano,
we're under attack. It's happening in New
York. Things are crazy. More or less just
saying we were, we're under attack. The country's
under attack. And Mr. Paul Massano looked
at him in the context of this is a guy who's
always interrupting class and sort of a troublemaker
and not particularly well behaved and just
didn't believe it and said, you know what,
I'm sure everything's fine. Please just sit
down. And of course we later found out that
it was true. And, um, I don't think that there
was early dismissal, but I certainly went
home and was just watching TV.
Uh, the rest of the day. And the following
day Mr Palmisano actually apologized to the
student and said, you know what? You were
right. I apologize for how I reacted. And,
uh, it's, it's horrible what's happened. And
we just had a conversation in psychology class
about what had gone on. Um, since then with
each passing year. Uh, in some senses our
perspective on what took place changes and
evolves partially just because when things
are less recent, our point of view is altered.
I don't think any of us can control this also,
partially because we know more about what
the legacy has been. And for me, unfortunately
the legacy of nine 11 in the United States
has been pretty bad. Uh, we started a war
in the wrong place as a result of nine 11
against people who didn't do the thing that
we claimed was the reason for starting the
war.
We have seen pervasive, persistent and also
effective privacy invasions as a result of
nine 11 under the guise of national security.
We've seen the Patriot Act, we've seen NSA
surveillance, all of that stuff that we've
talked about over the last many years. Post
nine 11 that the David Pakman show has been
going on, we have become really accustomed
to the persistent state of the global war
on terror. Uh, the permanent war status quo
of we're always somewhere for many years it's
been Afghanistan, a presence in Iraq that
never seems to end. Other potential engagements,
all sort of under this post nine 11 mentality
of we've got to make sure that people out
there who want to harm us aren't able to do
it and that we're projecting strength and
all of this stuff. One of the elements of
the legacy of nine 11 sort of the, the high
points, not in terms of them being morally
good or bad, but just notable was the Obama
administration capture of Osama bin Laden.
And then of course subsequently everything
we learned about the lead up to that and the
people that were involved. We've seen a legacy
of continued ignorance and it's really more
than ignorance. It's really more of a deliberate
kind of bearing our heads in the sand, many
of us about what creates radicalism through
foreign policy. And this is not, you know,
very often when we talk about foreign policy
creating radicals who want to attack the United
States, it becomes a very sort of mannequin
white, black thing of listen, either people
are responsible for choosing to attack the
United States, or you're saying that they
lack all responsibility and it's just the
fault of the u s through foreign policy for
radicalizing people. And of course the answer
is no, that's not the black and white scenario
that anyone who's thoughtful is trying to
lay out. One of the things we've hopefully
learned over the 18 years since nine 11, is
that radicalization, both domestically and
geopolitically, whether we're talking about
white supremacy or or Islamic, uh, um, extremism
or whatever the case may be, is a combination
of, uh, circumstances domestically, which
are influenced by the foreign policies of
super powers like the United States combined
with the particular, uh, predispositions and,
uh, sort of, uh, circumstances of individuals.
All of the white supremacists and former white
supremacists. I've interviewed on the show
have told a very consistent story about how
they know who is sort of ripe for radicalization
and indoctrination and in the same way when
we talk about al Qaeda or isis or whatever,
we're not excusing the actions of individuals
when we say we should consider the role that
the relationships between countries and American
foreign policy have on creating an environment
ripe for radicalization. While understanding
that millions, tens of millions, hundreds
of millions, billions of people on the planet
are not apt to be radicalized regardless of
foreign policy. These things are not black
and white and hopefully if there's a positive
legacy from nine 11 and I know that for a
lot of people this just doesn't work, but
hopefully the more thinking people are aware
of this stuff, hopefully one of the positive
legacies of nine 11 if there's anything to
find in it, is that we have sort of deepened
our understanding of the interaction between
personal circumstances, personal responsibility
and geopolitical status quo in creating radicalization
around the world.
We also have seen continued neo-conservative
war hawking on a lot of the right and even
on some of the left as a result of nine 11.
Um, in terms of even justifying, uh, attempted
or would be engagements in other parts of
the world over the last 18 years. Airport
security and the establishment of the TSA
of course a major legacy of nine 11 and unfortunately
not one of the best ones. TSA, a failing to
identify banned items in almost 95% of internal
self tests, drills, so to speak of their security
processes. So sadly it is mostly negative.
There was, I mean, if we want to find something
that was sort of good that happened after
nine 11, um, that of course doesn't outweigh
any of the bed. There was actually a short
lived positive sort of sense of unity in the
United States where hyper partisanship was
mitigated a little bit.
And it was about coming together as a country
and helping people in New York City and in
Washington, D C and all of the people affected
by nine 11. And it didn't last long. And it's
not surprising that it was these sort of black
swan type events. To take a term from, uh,
Nassim Taleb who has written about such events,
um, that really kind of shook up the status
quo. It didn't last very long. And of course
then the administration of George W. Bush
choosing to retaliate to nine 11 by going
into Iraq, which had nothing to do with it,
did not help at all. My question to you, how
should we be remembering nine 11 as we get
closer and closer to 20 years out from the
event, which is just incredible that almost
20 years have gone by. Uh, and what do you
see as the legacy of nine 11 on geopolitics
on United States foreign policy, domestic,
uh, issues and the status quo? I want to hear
from you.